delegate time is your most important
resource divide your life into 10-minute
units and sacrifice as few of them as
possible in meaningless activity in VAR
comp rock founder of ikea i wasted a lot
of time yesterday and I should have
known better if you look very carefully
you'll notice that my logo and my
newsletter is slightly different from
the logo that's on my youtube channel
the orange plane is at a slightly
different angle who cares I do because
quality is doing it right when nobody is
looking how did this happen I have no
idea how do we fix it this is what got
me in the trouble I thought it'd be a
quick fix and because I have pretty good
photoshop skills i figured it's a
one-time thing that i can fix myself and
move on boy was I wrong turns out we
have to make it a vector so if we scaled
at any size if I wanted to tattoo Evan
Carmichael believe on the moon and have
my orange playing at just the right
angle we could do it hmm that's an
interesting thought I actually really
need it for a t-shirt line that I'm
launching but I'm not supposed to talk
about that yet as I got deeper and
deeper into this quick project I got
more and more frustrated this was above
my skill level this was more work than I
anticipated this was not something I had
a personal interest in learning it was
time to delegate find someone who loves
making vector graphics or insert
whatever skill you need and give it to
them to do so you can focus on where you
add the most value grow in your business
as soon as I found someone to help me in
this case a quick job on fiverr com my
mood lifted I calmed down I regained my
focus I was happier and I could get back
to growing my business be the CEO just
because you're good at something that
doesn't mean you should do it just
because something needs to get done it
doesn't mean that you need to be the one
who does it am i walking to work every
morning I think to myself what's the
most value i can add to my business
today and then i go do that
find other people to help you even as
for five dollars a time at fiver if you
want to build something great then you
need to have a great respect for your
time you shouldn't be doing at least
fifty percent of the things you're doing
right now in your business stop breathe
and delegate belief